JACOB ROSENBERG: It's
an online direct lender
that is a socially responsible
alternative to payday loans
that makes loans online to
people whom banks and credit
unions would normally decline.
It's really important to
us morally as a company
to contribute the positive
repayment behavior that people
are giving, that people are
doing as they use our products,
and that we share that.
Because that's the
way that you reward
people for the
positive behavior.
If you talked to many
companies in the space,
they will tell you
that they don't
want to report that information
because why would they
want to tell everybody who
their best customers are?
But the truth is, we just
think it's a moral imperative
that you be rewarded
for the right behavior.
And it really ties in
with our first value here,
which is ladders not chutes.
We always want to be building
products that help people up
on the landscape of
financial health.
And we always think
about, when we're
building a product,
if someone uses it,
whether they're going to be
better off a year from now
or not.
And if they're not, we don't
want to build that product.